some surprising news out of the Star  Trek universe when et spoke with John  Cho on the set of Star Trek beyond he  revealed that Sulu has a baby daughter  but also told us to expect more big news  about his character you have no idea who  we are there isn't another revelation  that you'll find out in regards to the  into this baby but then you'll have to  wait to see the movie you couldn't miss  soon turns out Sulu is gay it's gonna  get bananas yeah yeah up in here up in  here yes Sulu has both a daughter and a  husband the actor told the news to  Australia's Herald Sun while promoting  the new movie the decision was inspired  by George Takei who played the original  Sulu in the 1960 series and who is also  gay our thoughts well as one Trekkie fan  tweeted what a time to be alive